guten tag con finiti a good target the
time
guten tag Susanna recent Infiniti
willkommen zu einer neuen episode don't
challenge from Canada in this area for
their and uns hello Smith's ferret
dentist initiative
alright now have separated the table so
one half here and the other one five
meters away
[Applause]
good one
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
yes it's time to play with a chair
fabulous this way I thought it was no
way
[Applause]
cool I wasn't sure like which way the
birthday chair
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
No
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah just can't keep so hard are hard
know what I want okay now let's do one
shot with each leg
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah come on just when I got it more
let's try the shushing ball catch with a
non Chinese rubber
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's okay a few a few bounces wasn't
perfect we can do better
[Music]
there we have it the gym ball cat
[Music]
yeah perfect catch with a wooden blade I
think it should be a bit more difficult
[Music]
[Applause]
not too bad
danke Schon - Timon remember to
subscribe here and check out previous
videos there is two nests month later
whoreson yeah